[Music]
hey friends what's going on so a quick
practice tip today where I'm going to
show you these four common chords right
your C major your a minor your G and
then your F right now pick your poison
when it comes to how you play the F
whether you do the full bar chord or the
middle four strings or the thinnest four
strings right I'm going to show you some
cool ways though when you're playing
these four chords which often come
together I'm going to show you some cool
ways to sort of spice them up in a way
that sounds good uh and it's using just
a few tricks Each of which you can apply
to any of the chords here so it's a
great very economical way to add some
spice to any song that's using these
four chords so um first let's look at
the chords and then I'll get into some
of the the tricks right so the c major
I'm going to assume you know that one
it's pretty standard right same with the
a minor okay very similar those two
chords are and the g you know I like to
play it like this a lot of the time
where I basically have my index finger
free as opposed to this which kind of
limits you because you can't really do
much up here um in other keys this this
voicing has its place but for this
exercise I recommend you play the G like
this ring finger middle finger and then
Pinky Okay on the third second and third
fret of the six Fifth and first strings
right and then your f instead of doing
the six string bar chord F here we're
actually going to be doing any one of
these whether it's the middle four
strings right or maybe it's the F major
7 right or maybe you like that F ad n
right um any of these are going to be
sort of our wheelhouse for this because
we want to have some flexibility that
having the full bar doesn't really give
us and I'm going to explain why in a
second so now that we know the four
chords let's talk about some ways you
can spice them up in a consistent manner
the first is going to be
basically putting your uh middle finger
of your left hand on and off on all
these chords now check this out
basically on the
[Music]
C our uh middle finger is here on this e
note it's the second fret of the fourth
string and basically we can sort of lift
that middle finger up and then put it
back
down we can do that while the rest of
our fingers are saying in that c major
position okay whatever you want to do
whether you want to get some hammer on
some pull offs or
just all right now let's uh make this
interesting by showing that on some
different chords as well for the F what
you could do is just do maybe an F major
here okay so that's a third second first
fret and then open um on the high E
string
[Music]
we're basically going to take our middle
finger off again and put it back down
this time we're on the third string but
it's the same idea right so let's just
do
[Music]
the so I'm basically going from that c
to the F major 7 my index finger staying
still the entire time and all I'm doing
is on both chords liftting up that
middle finger putting it down
[Applause]
and if you play the F by just doing the
middle four strings you can do the same
thing okay in this voicing I'm actually
not sort of making any sound with the
the thickest and thinnest string so I'm
muting them okay but
[Music]
basically you can do that same
deal now you can also do this on the a
minor
but here I'll say instead of just doing
the middle finger you might want to take
the ring finger off
[Music]
too and you can combine that with the
other chords
[Music]
right okay and with the G what we're
going to be doing is taking the middle
finger off of the fifth
string
right okay now that we have that that
one trick we can just sort of jam
through all the chords in whatever order
you want right
okay so that's a way off the bat to take
those four chords and add a bit of spice
but let's look at something else we can
do one is very similar we're basically
going to be doing the same thing with
our index finger and you'll notice that
your index finger is on this B string
first fret for all four all three of
those Chords it's not there for the G
but it's there for the C
it's there for the a
minor it's there for the F
right so let's do the middle fourth
string
F right or maybe you're doing the F add
n or maybe you're doing the F major
7 right and then for the
G what we're going to do is add the
finger
and with this one what I like to do is
actually not play the fifth string I
sort of I mute it by leaning my ring
finger into
[Music]
it right and that uh avoids a dissonant
Sound by having a b note here and a C
note here right it can kind of sound a
little bit
funky it works but I like the cleanness
of
this so we could add that to the bag of
tricks and then just sort of keep on
strum
[Music]
in okay and then the last one I'll show
you here is this trick with your pinky
finger on the third fret of the high E
string right this is a g e note and you
can sort of play
this on and off with all these chords
it'll sound good right the C it sounds
great because this G note is in the c
major
chord um so it sounds nice and
appropriate for the a
minor it turns it into an A Minor 7
which is
nice and for the F we can go from the F
major 7 to The Fad
9 right
and then to the G we're going to be
there anyway so there's really not much
to do
um but with those all together now I'm
just going to go through the chords and
sort of show you some cool little riffy
Diffy you can do right so
[Music]
okay so um really improvisation is your
friend there just kind of pick a little
exercise that feels good for you as far
as whether it's the index finger the
pinky or the middle finger and just you
know pick two or three of the chords you
don't have to do all four just sort of
go through them have some fun um
experiment that's you know it's it's all
in good fun when it comes to music but
that's going to be it for this lesson
just quick practice tip um I really
wanted to uh to share with you guys so
if you appreciate this you can check out
my website playong notes.com you can
find the notes and tabs that I use for
some of this lesson as well as all my
other lessons uh thanks to all of you
who support me on patreon uh I hope you
are appreciating the uh the nice PDFs I
am making for each of these lessons it's
a great way to sort of follow outside of
this video I trust but uh you know uh
thanks for watching if this is your
first time here please subscribe and
tell a friend if you like what you saw
and I have plenty more coming so I'm
going to head off now now check out the
rest of my uh Channel if you like these
sort of tips or if you want to learn
some songs or whatever else this has
been David Potts have a great night my
friends bye-bye